we should jump to the next segment yes
because we have only so much time laughs
that is true oh gosh yeah this is this
is a amazing film review yes a movie
called [ __ ] angry unemployed and full of
alt-right stoked rage cups protagonist
is ready to explore in Rob Lambert's
discomforting if over rigged character
study October 2nd 2019 have you ever
heard the saying my friends get woke go
broke
yes familiar it is the the movie
personification of it well wonderful
well the it's it's it's a what is it
like a truism I guess it's not it's not
really always true somewhat gross - oh
no yeah I guess the Invisible Man made
money but it was like trash right people
I don't know some people liked it it
wasn't it wasn't like overt wolken it's
like this is over-the-top it's basic I
can't I there's still a part of me that
thinks that this movie doesn't exist it
doesn't exist this is the Shazam look at
that what is that what is that the genie
movie with what's-his-name Kazan Kazan
that's what this is the Kazan never
happened never take a look take a look
what is that what does that say zero US
dollars zero zero how is that possible I
think it's a mistake I think you guys
what I'm saying I feel like there's
something wrong the movie cuck I don't
get from National file calm the movie
cook-maid zero does the box-office
I don't know what that source is News
Guard for whatever they're worth says
it's not you know reliable here's a
reddit post from kotaku in action'
saying the movie cook made zero dollars
the box-office win was the in the box so
when was it actually released in the
movie my understanding so I have the
Wikipedia here for it and they say that
it was really the release date in the
United States was October 4th 2019 Tober
fourth go zero dollars that's got to be
a mistake wait what else what else came
out October 4th
I have no idea is there another do you
want it you want to try and look like
totally blew it out of the water and
everyone's like hmmm what should we go
see this big huge blockbuster this huge
or cut oh let's go to these I have not
seen cook i will not see cuck it's got a
terrible audience score but check this
out
romesco went on a favor
compared cuck to todd phillips 2019 film
joker calling it more repellant honest
and astute than this week's odds on a
box-office champion so that's saying
that Joker came out the same time is it
no I don't know so here's what the
movies about though let's get to the
point okay basically it's some dude and
he gets radicalized by YouTube YouTube
does it yes yes his online vlog and then
he starts building a following and it
makes him crazy I guess okay
I remember hearing about this around
then but I just didn't care I really I
really can believe it made zero dollars
yeah because they put it in select
theaters and then no one cared to go and
see it and right and so it made no so it
wasn't like a big movie putting all
theaters it was like specific ones well
they chose the wrong theater right
I see Joker on the same time look at
this they wrote this this is variety and
this is October 2nd if this weekend
you're only seeing one depressing
character study about an unemployable
fatherless antisocial manchild who lives
with his sickly mother is often
unattractively shirtless and eventually
decides society must pay violently for
his general misery then you are almost
certainly going to see Joker
if it happens however there's an there's
an alternative also fitting the
description perfectly well Cook is in
fact Joker with even less vestige of
superheroes than Todd films a typical
comic book movie about precisely the
sort of people some have feared will
take Joker as an incitement to
real-world violence the usually white in
cell type man who feels marginalized and
somehow robbed of success who in
worst-case scenarios ends up shooting up
a school workplace or other public space
so to feel his rage isn't entirely
impotent but guess what what day the
joker came out October 4th
yep same day heared so now I know now I
know why it made zero so one of the best
movies in the past 20 years overshadowed
it completely I'm not seeing it on my
list here though I just put up that
pulled up the Joker wiki $0 like hmm the
Joker or the Wikipedia doesn't mention
it make
jokerz yeah this is um look at this
let's read the plot right here you read
even have the whole movies oh wait wait
wait
spoilers it's not one time I wouldn't
give a spoiler warning it's it's a
simple paragraph okay
brooding loner Ronnie lives this
possessive mother in the wasteland of
Van Nuys rejected from the military for
mental instability and petty crime
he eats out a dismal existence Ronnie's
only world is the one he makes online on
his computer after creating a vlog
channel on the downfall of real America
he rails from his video platform against
those he perceives as enemies as Ronnie
gains confidence from the online
extremist community his channel grows
meanwhile sexual frustration leads him
to a local swinger couple who pay him to
play cuckold in their homemade amateur
pornography unaware that they are
exploiting him he accepts the role and
its rewards Ronnie buys an unregistered
handgun and strokes his ego at firing
ranges he meets his online idol a
charismatic leader of the alt-right
however when his identity as cuck
emerges his macho persona shatters
facing online shaming Ronnie takes
solace in the one symbol of masculinity
has left his gun it's literally about a
dude trying to join the alright because
he was radicalized on YouTube well I'm
not surprised nobody saw it nobody cared
because that sounds like garbage yeah
you see they've made movies that use
legitimate intellectual property like
Ghostbusters make it woke and some
people do go see it right they complain
about it after the fact this movie has
no legitimate IP behind it it's just
woke stupid narratives and nobody wanted
to go see it the people who went to go
see Ghostbusters were like I like
Ghostbusters right and then when they
realized what it was they're like this
movie is awful yeah now they're remaking
Ghostbusters as like unoriginal I can
actual sequel append is it yeah it's a
real sequel a real sequel I haven't
really read into it yet the trailer come
out the kid from strangers things isn't
it is it
I think so I think Paul Rudd's in it
right and it's basically like I think
Egan's kids or something oh yeah they're
the trailers out and he says something
like no one's seen a ghost in 30 years
so it's an actual seek like
the Third's you know sequel to the
second one sweet totally discount they
were supposed to do this I remember when
the ghost was thing all happened yeah
and it was like I'm not sure if those
Harold Ramis or somebody said I'd be
interested in an all-female cast and
then all sudden they were like they
changed what was supposed to be a sequel
to the first two yeah into an alternate
reality you know they were gonna do like
a ghostbusters universe really they want
to do like East Coast Ghostbusters and
West Coast Ghostbusters or something
left-field Oh totally failed they're
like because everybody wanted to do a
movie universe after Marvel started
getting big mm-hmm and it's shocking to
me no one figured it out like you
realize Marvel just made a series of
movies and then kind of like barely
connected them yeah it's like you watch
the movie at the very end they'd be like
Thor and that was it it was like a
preview after the credits got ya sit
through the credits I said through the
mom I'm an Avengers brought it all
together mm-hmm and that's how they had
the universe yep and then what is like
DC try to do let's just make Justice
League it's like but you've never
established any of these characters I
know yeah yeah and then they made a
comment after it like how does that make
sense he was he was a nobody in that
movie like how did he how did they what
are you doing that's a good plan anyway
so so for some reason they decided to
make a send you know you know what maybe
this is their gamble that Joker was DC
and maybe they were thinking if we do
one that's based on real-life politics
people might go see it so basically make
the same movie as Joker but make it
about the alt-right and make it about
America yeah and call it [ __ ] and then
people are gonna you know what this is
this is evidence that people really
overestimate the value of Twitter hmm
the Internet is not real life yeah good
mice are real we're literally just some
random people in a basement complaining
about stuff there's always there's
always those like just alternate version
movies that come out too right right
everything like like bugs life and ants
yes I know but
but that's those are actually both okay
movies I'm talking like the the top
grossing film and then the one that like
is all d-list actors that you don't know
anyone but actually the the main kit or
not even the main character there's the
one guy that they paid for like two
scenes yeah that was recognizable
because he was like an extra in one
blockbuster film you know there's like
go on that's what cook seems like to me
go on Amazon and you'll see this
there'll be like the iron hero right
it's like Iron Man but the lowest
quality yes you know they do it though
right because they know some people will
be tricked into watching it exactly
Oh what was this Iron Man and you watch
for 10 minutes and you're like oh no I
paid for this yeah I've watched some of
those movies that it's it's sometimes
it's funnier yeah they're funny they're
so bad they're so bad they're funny and
some people actually like that like the
kind of movies that they're so bad they
laugh at the horrendous acting and
writing yeah I could go on but how come
how come birds of prey couldn't do that
you know I'm sorry I'm sorry they change
the name Harley Quinn birthday oh yeah
but then now I'm seeing it back as I I
don't know they need to make up their
minds baby so we can make fun of it
correctly i I want to be fair it's
possible this cook film is a good movie
it's possible I'm not gonna see it
though I don't know anybody who wants
the end apparently nobody did see it's
only know one dude here's the best part
apparently it was released on DVD
already like is that did they say when
it was released on them yes um someone
posted this that it was uh it came out
in October let's say on June 19 2019 it
was announced that gravitas ventures had
acquired the distribution it was
officially released in select theaters
Google Play as well on October 4th wait
it's on Amazon theaters and VOD i don't
i think the zero zero dollars thing is
wrong it's got to be wrong i mean i
don't know cuz you'd imagine hey listen
i met in amazon over amazon prime would
randomly suggest it at some point right
and someone might like come on one
person bought it what look you know it
you know i think it's what's at zero
dollars in the box office right oh
that's right no see it in the theaters
that makes sense so but I have to
imagine even the show's producers might
just dump some money to make it seem
like come on man I mean think about it
though it's expensive to go to the
movies even if you gotta want to see
them get to go to the movies nowadays so
you're saying more people are wise
getting wiser with their money I I think
and it would hope that any
you know it's like and it came out the
same day as the Joker like the Joker
he's like one of the biggest villains of
our lives a good movie and it was an
amazing movie but like Batman and the
Joker it's like they've been fighting
each other for a long time it's like
everybody knows who the Joker is so so
so here is the scenario the the people
who literally made cuck mm-hmm it was
released and instead of seeing their own
movie went to see The Joker instead yeah
they're like why don't and they're like
this is it our movies in the theater you
ever see Joker hood but the Joker comes
out today it's like they're walking down
the red carpet but they rolled it out
themselves well love the audience look
at this the audience score is 34%
so apparently look 88 people watched it
boom that's some money and I wonder if
they had to be paid alright alright
alright so look I didn't see it so it's
not a fair review but I feel bad for the
actors why would you do this stuff don't
just don't just stay away from it don't
don't put it on your resume nope do not
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you